you guys remember if you want to be
successful learn from the other people's
mistakes I think everybody can be
successful if you really try try a hard
every problems
I met invite when I was a kid benefited
me once or get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best Jack Ma and some of his top advice
for success mentor me Jack
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn from the mistakes of others my
thinking is that you guys remember if
you want to be successful learn from the
other people's mistakes don't learn from
the successful stories successful
stories they make don't listen to that
there are a lot of reasons behind it
just like god I remember the first time
Harvard Business School came to us say
Jack we want to write a case study for
you
yes years 2001 a 2000 they came they
spent one week and they write a report
and I read no I said this is not me and
this is this is you as a no this is not
us
is that this is you so they make up his
sign and they case study go up and
instead to teaching I love universities
the next five years they invite to need
to go to the case study and they always
find a competitor of my company and F
after every case that case study
Ali Baba died that company will succeed
all the students agree and actually
every five years all the competitive
dive is to survive so how can you study
this kind of a success of a start
learn from the mistakes the other people
no matter how smart you are you will
encounter these mistakes you learn from
mistakes not because you will be able to
avoid mistakes you were able to when
these mistakes come they suffer comes
you know how to deal with it how to face
it
I like the book I want to write if I if
I want if I can
it's a re Bubber 1001 mistake this is
the most rational things that in my life
in my life is not how much we achieved
is how much we call through the tough
days and mistakes and this is what is it
if you step to think now would be good
rule number two try hard I think
everybody can be successful if you
really try try a hard
I started Alibaba 1999 in my apartment I
talked to the 18th founders that one
thing we want one of the things we want
to prove if Jack - team can be
successful 80% of the people in the
world they can be successful because we
don't have money would have technology
will have almost nothing the only thing
is that we believe in the future and
instead to do little by little also if
you want to have more confidence check
out my 250 for series it's free the link
to join is in the description below it's
so difficult to be a small business in
China it took me five months to borrow
$500 the people who do the bottom should
believe in the model and I believe what
I do
rule number three solve big problems we
are not a company that normally China
Khanna we call ourself accompanied
running a platform a company that is
running an ecosystem we are almost
everywhere people say Jack you know you
are in the b2b and b2c and you're
calling CTV on a finance and online
payment logistic cloud computing you are
everywhere not because we're greedy not
because we want to do
because we have to do it if we cannot if
we do not to do it
China ecommerce in the years were
collapse
I remember nine years ago when I started
that alley pay people say yet don't
touch the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison and I we
taught our self if we don't do it the
China e-commerce were always like a like
a chat room everybody said it's a good
thing and yeah I don't pay you don't get
the things so I say well put me in the
prison let's make a shirt that Ali pay
the payment solution works and people
said the payment solution is such a
stupid idea it's an escrow service I pay
you hold of money and you get the things
you pay the money if you don't get the
things you want return the money
they said it's a stupid product and I
say as long as you solve the problem
I like stupid things you know let's make
stupid things smart keep on improving
every day rule number four never give up
that's a young boy I never thought but
you know it's a young boy if ever today
I never thought I would be here honestly
I never thought but as a young boy I
probably when I look back every problems
I met invite when I was a kid benefited
me I filled so many times people
probably know that I've applied jobs for
so many jobs over 30 jobs all rejected
not even got a chance to the four of us
an interview for a KFC job 23 accepted I
was the only guy rejected
six people went fuller looking for a
police job five except I was the only
one my cousin I applied job as a as a as
a server in a full style to my city we
wait a long queue for two hours he was
accepted I really really so my mother
looked at me huh
you know yes but I know this is a
training course for me before my thirty
years old I'm a failure people lose by
never give up I think there is
opportunity there and then I I was a
teacher later I read from University I
was teaching the universe for six years
number five because number five year I
was elected the best a teacher of my
universe elected by students
so I said everything I taught my
students are the things I learned from
books what if I go out to spend a 10
years experience all the things whether
fail or succeed I'd go back to teach
again that was my original thing and
doing Alibaba so I never thought I could
be rich I never thought it would be
successful I never thought we could
survive for 18 years and then we made it
and rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip is think ahead
every five years we have a review for
our strategy now our strategy is always
a look at the 30 years and ten years
every strategic decisions we make we
have to ask one question this decision
we make solve society problem because we
believe the bigger social property you
solve the most successful you are so if
we do it this cannot solve any social
problems we don't do it second is this
project is going to be successful
in 10 years if it's it's going to be
successful in 10 years let's do it
if it's going to be successful in one
year or one month normally I say forget
about it because why you can be
successful in one year or one mouth so
we all have to put param and five years
ago we had a big debate about 10 years
later 20 years what are the things this
China society the world leave want so we
say happiness and health
to H strategy to happen is in health we
believe Holly you know the movie
industry bring people happy because
today nobody is happy
rich people not happy poor people not
happy you know at least when I watch
movie a few happy but right so I think
we should partner with the Hollywood
especially like a lot of you know we
have a different way of living and in
China the movie we have a lot of heroes
but China movies heroes always dead an
American movie here will never die if
all the heroes die who want to be the
hero so my movie I want to make the hero
live right so this is this is I think we
should learn a lot and it's all about
two years so we have another eight years
ago I want to make our company that it's
not ecommerce it's something that giving
people inspirations given people because
I learned a lot for example I will say
that my favorite movie forest the gum
you know life is tough this is I learned
and that inspired me that is why when
people call me crazy stupid pass the 70
years you're crazy I tell you something
never work you're stupid how can do that
model
Emma's in this model eBay this model why
help about this model I told myself
Forester gum said or a hat I would care
about what the other people and the
other thing first calm said nobody make
money out of the catching whales people
make money by catching shrimps so we
serve small business
now I've got a special bonus cup from
Jack on how to surround yourself with
greatness that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to take an
action here we go question number one
what will you never give up on number
two what big problem are you trying to
solve and number three what have you
learned from the mistakes of others how
do i emot-- to buy incentive unload by
by our colleagues you have to find the
people become mobilize themselves it's
impossible to find to to encourage an
active person so the people you're high
that people work together they they have
to be oh you cannot we have a 65,000 in
price now you cannot hire all of them
that positive but at least the people
work with me my management leadership
several areas they have to be positive
they have to know the to incentive the
others because I cannot accept everybody
and making sure the culture so I think
it would be very painful for me to talk
to my vice president and he need to be
incentivized and mobilized every time
right this won't work if he is not if he
does not know how to incentivize or
mobilize his people it's better I don't
think he will be the vice president it
should be a good engineer good designer
but not good leader a good leader should
know how but not by only money most of
people incentive lies or move on not
because you give them a lot of money you
give the respect trust appreciation and
correct heartful advice
when it come to my meetings internal
meetings you'll be shocked because we
we're not like a lot of other Chinese
company the boss they ever listen take
notes and go now we are like a war room
we make this issue based a whose voice
is louder early days you know slider the
talk and then making sure everybody
speak up right so this is also a way of
mobile life and incentives there are a
lot of ways and different people have a
different way to send incentive
if you want to know nine surprising
facts about Jack Ma check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there for nine years
every morning almost no weather snow
rain or Sun I went there looking for
foreign tourists to become the free
guide